four and a half million people are
internally displaced in syria most of
them live in refugee camps here in the
northwest
they depend on food medicine and other
basics that are brought in via the
bubblehouse border crossing with turkey
these food boxes contain rice sugar and
oil none of these are within our means
we rely on these containers
however damascus says delivering
international aid to opposition-held
areas violates its sovereignty it wants
humanitarian relief to be routed through
government-held territory
stopping aid will be a disaster in every
sector including medicine food and
education we urge the international
community to keep politics and
humanitarian aid as separate issues
many believe russia's threat is in
retaliation for western countries
providing support to ukraine during its
month-long invasion
doctors fear what's coming
russian pressure to cut aid would create
a crisis that would force more syrians
to be displaced and die while trying to
survive
more than 4 600 u.n trucks mostly
carrying food have used the crossing in
the first six months of 2022.
the un's babel hawa corridor is the best
it's transparent safe and cost-effective
none of the alternatives are better if
it's closed even preventable deaths may
not be stopped
the un estimates 13.4 million syrians
needed assistance last year up from 11.1
million in 2020.
most goods in northwestern syria are
imported from government controlled
areas or here in turkey but as the lira
loses its value and the food prices soar
because of the war in ukraine it is only
compounding the crisis for millions of
people who are dependent on
international aid cnam kyo solo al
jazeera istanbul